normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government the
unhoused thing is like I I think it's
leftist double speak to
manipulate uh public policy positions
because you don't like Define house
right so what we're saying is somebody
who lives in some kind of structure but
it's not a house so they're unhoused
what's a home right it's it's it's
saying unhoused is applying a material
position and and and like a resource
number to what a person is required to
have I'm personally not offended by the
term homeless I'm fine to use it but
given that that's what people who I know
who work on this issue you I just follow
their lead unhoused you don't need a
house heard people that live on you can
live in someone else's couch and be and
be homeless okay so like the when when
you say someone's unhoused it's the
implication that they should be housed
but
what why should they be housed you you
you deserve a house you you deserve a
home somewhere to live a home is
different from a house okay sure I'm but
I'm happy to call it unhomed if that you
know I think it's just I think it's
manipulative double speak to control a
narrative and shift and gradually shift
position I know dud give people houses
or people that have slept on the street
that say I have a home and it's right
over there on Fifth Avenue so don't call
me homeless and I'm like well you're
sleeping out in the open and it's like
yeah but that's my home if you rent your
friend's couch are you homeless no you
have a home it's the your your couch but
you're uned technically not you would be
unhoused yes you would I I don't I don't
like this manipulative double speak
where they change language and change
the defition you don't need paperwork to
have a home or a house you just need to
literally some but the issue ultimately
comes down to what do you say to a man
of sound mind who chooses to not have a
home and live outside don't poop on my
street that's number one I watched a
homeless person from my window one time
poop on my car
yeah I called I called the police and I
said hey I I don't know if this concerns
you there's a person pooping on my car
what should I do they were like you got
a hose yeah and I was like no I don't I
don't got a hose and they were like well
you might want to get a hose sooner than
later cuz that stuff's acrylic yeah it
wasn't good acidic it wasant if somebody
if somebody makes the choice to not have
a home and they're so resourceful and so
skilled that they can live out in the
world like that I say respect I mean
good for you that's that's amazing I can
never do that I don't say it again in I
but I don't think that's what most you
know don't think most people who live on
the streets I don't think it's a it's a
choice I think they're put there by
circumstances beyond their control when
I when I worked for the shelter Network
I did 80% was a choice yeah I think 0%
80% do you understand why that's hard to
believe because you've never worked in
the industry and you don't know anything
about you don't have no idea talking
about I did spend a summer this is I'm
sorry I I spent one summer working with
the on house population who you you you
think a guy who but it sounds like you
have more experience than I do because I
just spent one summer I it's just like
walking walk go to California
go to La go to go like West some areas
in Westwood I know UC Al is up there so
you don't they push a lot of the stuff
out but I remember going to a shopping
center somewhere uh where was I um
somewhere near Hollywood slightly west
of Hollywood and it's like five homeless
guys all living up against side of a
building and a and a lady gets out of
the tent walks in the middle of the
street just takes a dump yeah and when
you go to them and be like we got a bed
we got a private room and they say F you
cuz the shelters are terrible they've
all probably had terrible experience
some of them are full houses a five
bedom house and you'd go to someone and
be like how would you like keys to a
house and a bedroom and they go you got
a manager there I'm like we do never
going to happen we're like well I don't
know what to tell you man okay so look I
can't extrapolate based on that that
that applies then to the majority of the
community I I just can't maybe you're
right but regardless why not try at
least why not give the opp what do you
think all these nonprofits are doing
well I think they're working within a
very tough system to do what they can
but the resources I think the problem is
Democrat spend money Wars so there
there's not there's not enough to give
people there I I don't know if it's a
one for one but I would agree with not
spending money on Wars and at least
giving a shot no let me tell you I'll
tell you this I would take every single
penny from every single warmonger and I
would give it to one homeless guy who
couldn't think straight because I'm just
like I can't stand this it's we're
better off we're better off because in
the long run we save money if we're not
engaging these print 3D print graphine
homes for people but the key is to get
them in to get them to want take a
shower and join the system when people
already checked out the system we had
some people who would stay in the there
were forever shelters and they were
temporary shelters and if you were a
consistent temporary shelter individual
they could upgrade you or move you to
the permanent shelter there were
legitimate people that I have met who
are like man I lost my job and I have no
friends and I don't know how to do
anything like you get me a job I'll do
whatever it takes these people have
recovered but these people don't exist
as much in like the reason why
homelessness tends not to be that is
because those people will give the
opportunity to leave instantly a guy is
homeless for 2 weeks the shelter comes
up and says we want to help you he goes
please I'll take whatever you got three
months later he's got a he's sharing an
apartment with a with with some other
guys a couple hundred bucks a month no
longer a homeless problem but the reason
why most homeless people you see in the
street are there is because they want to
stay there and don't want to leave in
Chicago for instance they use these
Bridges to make little Villages and they
in between each pillar there's like so
the way it works is there's sidewalk and
there's an elevated portion with pillars
and they set up beds in between each
section you will never get them to move
Jane's right there John's across the
street this is my town and so they're
covered in urine there's feces
everywhere they dump in the streets and
you show up and say we want to help you
and they go help with what we want to
give you a home and help you get out of
the situation I like my situation have a
nice day leave and so now we have the
problem of like in California tents
everywhere in DC it's happening tents
everywhere and it's leading to uh
needles in the streets I we we went to
man it's it's such it's so brutal with
this really nice little historic town in
Maryland and there were I took a picture
of syringes and condoms on the ground
and I'm like it's because we've become
and this this is why I say there's no
moral answer Americans do not want to
accept that you need some kind of
like harsh force and Authority when it
comes to what people are doing in public
yeah that's what I come down to used to
be people wearing suits everywhere they
went in the early 1900s and hats don't
know about all that
but there was heavy heavy social and
police enforcement you're walking around
drunk drunk in public they would lock
you up they still do sort of to the St
depending on the degree of drunkenness
but most people just ignore it now in my
experience people who are dealing with
addiction and me and mental illness and
other self-defeat really self harmful
Behavior are dealing with trauma
something really bad that's happened to
them from a very very young age and what
I would want to do in any kind of effort
to alleviate homelessness is address
that and it's not I I agree with you
that providing shelter and a home is not
is not a Panacea it's not a one- siiz
fits allall policies it have to come
with addressing the issues that make
people destitute and desperate in the
first place and that's a lot of that has
to do with suffering terrible
experiences from a very very young age
or at some point in their lives cultural
shifts and if you deal psychological
trauma and if you deal with that then
you might be able to have the kind of
shift that I think you're talking about
I can't vouch for your statistics I mean
you you've worked I'm talking about one
city by the way I'm not talking about
like every city in the country or
everywhere I've been but you're saying
that if you went around to all the
people in LA and offered them you know a
home a place to live my friend if you
the majority would not accept it
absolutely no question I mean look and
we still you might get physically hurt
yeah I and it's not because every single
homeless person is V I'm saying it's
because there there's a viral video of a
a homeless guy what did you guys see
this video he had the knife and he was
swinging at the lady who lived in the
building because some people are crazy
and if you have 3,000 homeless people
and you go around asking each and every
one of them you eventually counter
someone who gets agitated and crazy
they're scared because I mean they'll
take your stuff from you they'll they'll
try and control you they'll take away
your drugs they'll tell you what you can
and can't do they'll tell you when you
can go outside and when you can't go
outside yeah so nobody wants to be in
these situations but if you tell someone
we've got a place for you to sleep you
can get cleaned up they'll say okay and
then they'll start using it to amplify
the negative behaviors that were causing
the problems in the first place well
then I want to know why they have that
drive to perpetuate their negative
behaviors and I would bet do drugs I
would bet in 100 in 100% of cases it's
because of trauma because they've
suffered something horrible in their
lives and this is their way of dealing
with it you know we can see that for
people of privilege when they have an
issue that's self-defeating they have
some sort of adverse childhood
experience that they're not dealing with
so I'd want to know in every case what
what caused someone to be so self
harmful to themselves and other people
and I I have a friend who volunteers
every Saturday uh with homeless people
in LA and he has a different picture of
the community he serves than you've had
and I'm I'm not trying to um you know
negate your point you have your
experience and I respect it I just think
certain things that would need to happen
to address this issue haven't been tried
I I Tred to interface with the broken
people oneon-one and it's not scalable
after I like really emotionally
connected with like 50 broken humans I
started to go insane and I had to stop I
almost killed myself cuz it was so much
pain I had to had to empathize was so
much pain so that's not a sustainable
and then I'm just like should we just be
like those sometimes humans walk so far
psychologically they just walked off a
cliff now they're feral and we got to
treat them like wild animals or or can
every human be reach I think that's a
possibility but why shouldn't we do all
we can to try why not we put so much
effort into war why can't we try to do
everything we can to I actually think uh
it is our incessant need to try and help
actually which is is what contributing
massive to the problem and what I mean
by that is we have created a society
where we've enabled Mass homelessness
through these programs if there was no
food and no one gave them food then they
would just simply stop and it's and and
it's like the argument now as why I said
there's no moral answer humans would be
willing to accept um the the there's
there's activist groups like food not
bombs and they're like did you know it's
illegal to give homeless people food
it's really funny because you have these
uh signs in the forest everywhere saying
do not feed Bears they'll become
dependent and dangerous
yet you also have left doing activists
who are like we should set up a bunch of
food and give food out to people which
is also particularly offensive as I have
actually I having been an unhoused
person several times in my life the
implication that I was hungry simply
because I didn't have my own place to
live is like offensive like what do you
mean I I was playing guitar in the
subway once I was not homeless and a
woman asked me if I was hungry and I
said no but thank you for asking and
then she asked me if I needed a place to
sleep and I said it was really funny I
was playing guitar making pretty decent
money and I was just like I appreciate
the sentiment but I'm going to go back
to my two-bedroom in Bucktown and and
just play video games tonight and she
went huh like the assumption that people
who are playing music in the street
separate side note are homeless the
assumption that someone who might be
homeless is also hungry these are these
are all completely incorrect things and
I think it stems from these these uh
well-to-do liberal types in cities want
to help and I can respect it but they
actually make the problem worse but why
not be touched that someone feels
compelled to try to help somebody out
even if they got you wrong they read you
wrong that uh to try to help you I think
is a nice thing so I I'm not saying it's
not but if there's a dude who is
constantly doing drugs and you're like
you know what these drugs are really bad
for him but I'm going to help him make
sure he gets he gets the drugs done
right like I don't know if you're
actually helping the guy I think you
well it depends how if he's using if
he's using dirty water to you know uh
inject heroin then if you're giving him
clean needles I I do think that's
helping him because you're preventing
him from possibly you're helping to
prevent him from possi or you stop him
from doing drugs well you can't do that
though because the question is um why is
heing why is he doing drugs in the first
place and 100% of the time it's because
of some trauma and I'm very biased on
this I'm very biased on this because I
have a father who works on this stuff
you know do you know what caused like
the opioid crisis what caused the opioid
crisis so a large component of what's of
what causes it is someone gets injured
they get prescribed opioids and they get
addicted and they can't get off then
when the doctor Cuts them off abruptly
they go seek Black Market means of
getting it and creates a bunch of
criminals so it's it's not so much about
trauma but not everyone who gets injured
gets addicted to opioids question is but
a lot of people got prescribed it and
the prescriptions turned into addiction
not trauma be physical trauma you know
that be the company that made aspirin um
created heroin and started marketing it
to people who were addicted to
Morphine to help get them off it doing a
certainly huge problem but the question
is why is there that what does like look
look addiction drugs it gives you a
dopamine rush and then you get addicted
to that why do you have a need for a
dopamine rush and there's plenty of
research on this I recommend my dad's
work on his name is Gabor matate he's a
oh I love his work man I've been seeing
him all over TV lately yeah so you
anyway but I'm not going to speak for
his work but I'm just saying is consider
the possibility that people who are
addicted it's it's not the drugs in of
themselves it's what the drugs are doing
for their pain thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net